[Music]
yeah yeah why do you keep looking at me
like that
Klee huh how long have I known you I
don't know like two years mm-hmm
and in those two years I have never
asked you for a favor right no exactly
I'm cashing in that favor now let me
touch your fro no no God why cuz I said
no Henry tells a guy tell you you never
touch a black man's bro [ __ ] what do
you like 12% black let me know let me
tell you something the only thing black
about you is that goddamn fro I am black
oh you Rick watch this you Indian as
[ __ ] pick up put your head back right
now but that watch do it hey dude what
is your problem man what are you going
look you're ready starting to piss me
off
no means no cuz you ain't touching my
flow huh
I don't think you understand something
I'm gonna touch your throw whether you
like or not
try me [ __ ] I'm black enough to know
that you ain't touching my throat
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
calm down I know this is just a dream
that's gonna go sleep in every be done
in the morning
how'd you get in here I've always wanted
to ask you something outside like what
did you come to the Congo for you've
been here for three years three years
look one poor mother told you man I
won't talk about it I just had to get
away get away from something something
yo look you want to understand just stop
with all the questions and have some
water let me touch your front
[Music]
yeah it's true I like the Batman this
was body my wife is in the same Clinton
Hydroxycut commercial Hydroxycut